Hi Bill,
my name is Sam.
My question for you is why are we trying
to live on Mars and recreate earth there
by making it an atmosphere and soil and
water we can drink and such.
Why can't we take those ideas and
motivation and directed at our own
planet that we clearly need the help
with?
Why?
Why is it easier to start fresh on
another planet that get people talking
about our own?
Sam.
Sam,
you are my man.
you're thinking as I do.
Okay.
I meet a lot of people.
You know,
I'm the CEO of the Planetary Society.
We advanced based science and
exploration.
I encourage you to join and as I say
about the planetary society,
we are not crazy.
You meet a lot of people.
I meet a lot of people who want to go to
Mars and make it like earth.
Just as you're the very idea that you're
questioning and I think people don't,
first of all,
just don't grasp the scale of it.
It's a planet.
It's a whole planet.
It's not
a,
it's not a wetland that you can reclaim
and build a parking garage on top of.
It's.
It's a whole planet.
Furthermore,
this planet where you and I are from is
perfectly suited to us.
We our ancestors and their ancestors and
so on,
grew up here,
tuned to these environments,
to these climates that we have here on
earth and so people want to go to Mars
and the spirit of adventure.
Now,
as you may infer from my accent,
I'm from the United States and my a lot
of my ancestors came here from Denmark
and Europe and they set up shop and what
the colony of Massachusetts and then
they went all the way across North
America to a through Wyoming,
the state of Wyoming and now to the west
coast to to Washington state and
California,
and they did that in this great
tradition of pioneering spirit.
Just keep going,
keep expanding,
keep spreading out,
and human kind has done that.
You know,
everybody's from Africa or ancestors are
all from the continent of Africa and we
spread all over the world,
spread to Australia across open ocean.
The polynesians in canoes.
Oh right,
we're spreading now,
man.
We're going okay,
and so people think,
oh,
let's spread out and go to Mars.
It's a whole nother thing to go to Mars.
I tell people this all the time.
There is nothing.
There's hardly any water.
There's a little bit.
There is nothing to eat.
There is no air,
there's no air.
What?
We can build a bubble and you were
moving into cook the Martian rocks and
get the oxygen out of it.
Okay?
It's just not so easy.
Just as you asked them,
why don't we do that here on earth or do
use that same technology here on earth
and this is part my little mission as a
human.
No,
not CEO of the planetary society is
reminding everybody that we've got to
take care of the earth in order for us
all to live here.
There are seven point 3 billion people
as we're recording right now.
By 2050,
there will be nine and maybe even 10
billion people by the middle of the
century and they're all gonna.
Want to eat something and drink
something and water and wash and carry
on,
and that's going to take us taking.
It's going to require us to take much
better care of our own planet.
Now,
with that said,
I like to remind everybody also,
although you don't want to go to Mars
and have a permanent settlement,
there are colony.
You do want to have a base there just as
humankind has a base in the Antarctic
where scientists go and study the
Antarctic,
learn about the environment,
learn about our planet,
learn about ice,
and the are the earth's history and the
climate today,
and the greenhouse gases and the
effective industrial emissions and so
on.
All of these discoveries are made in
Antarctica.
If we were to discover evidence of life
on Mars,
something that was once alive,
they're the equivalent of a what a
geologist called stromatolites
fossilized bacteria that have turned to
stone.
It would be astounding if we found
something still alive there.
There are these recurring slope linear,
which is geology expression.
For what look like rivulets look like
little rivers.
They may be just rockfalls turned over
gravel.
That as a slightly different color than
the surrounding rock,
but everybody thinks right now that it's
water.
Everybody's pretty sure by everybody
talking about people at the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration,
NASA and European Space Agency,
Isa Jackson,
Japanese aerospace,
exploration,
Roscosmos.
Everybody believes that there's
recurring flows of water every Martian
summer when what must be some
subterranean,
some under sand ice melts and if we.
If you have liquid water anywhere on
earth,
there's something alive everywhere.
There's liquid water.
There's something alive.
If there's something alive on Mars and
we could prove it,
show it to ourselves with our spacecraft
or with human explorers walking around,
I would change the world.
It would be equivalent to the see the
discoveries that copernicus made,
that the earth goes around the so all
the planets go around the sun,
not the other way around,
or Galileo.
We're not the only a body out in the
cosmos.
We got the moon.
We in fact,
Jupiter has its own moons and these
other discoveries that were so profound
a,
if we were to find life on another
world,
it would.
It would change this one and there's one
more element that we at the of this that
we at the planetary society celebrate
these discoveries.
There's of life on Mars or on the moon
of Jupiter that is twice as much sea
waters,
the earth's called Europa.
You can see it with binoculars,
uh,
at night.
If we make this discovery of life,
it will not have been done by an
individual,
by Galileo or copernicus or Irene Curie.
It would be done by a society who
invested it's intellect and treasure in
this quest.
Let's go see what's out there.
Let's learn more about ourselves,
our past and,
and we all want to know whether or not
we're alone in the universe.
So if we look on these two worlds,
the earth and Mars and find life on both
of them that would suggest that life is
very common in the cosmos and this
would,
this would affect the way each and every
one of us feels about what it means to
be a living thing in the cosmos.
Would it means to have this place in
space?
As a great question?
Carry on.